[Music]
it's time for another Mortal Kombat two
years ago Warner Brothers presented us
with a new liveaction movie for the
popular franchise which comprises 12
games and has sold over 80 million
copies worldwide with Mortal Kombat 2 we
can soon look forward to the highly
anticipated sequel which is also
expected to be extremely brutal in our
new Original Episode we give you all the
latest information on the plot cast and
production of the video game adaptation
enjoy there was one thing about
particular that fans of the series found
lacking in the predecessor the aonomus
tournament the objective is to prevent
the 10th consecutive victory of Shang
sun and his henchmen which would give
outworld control of the Earth in the
first movie there was talk of this but
ultimately the villains were just trying
to prevent another contest from
happening at all part one ended with
Shang Sun admitting defeat in the battle
against Cole Young and his allies and
now vowing Revenge by returning with an
entire Army of course that doesn't sound
as if the Classic Tournament will
finally be featured in Mortal Kombat 2
however it was not yet clear at the time
whether the movie would be a success at
all so of course they wanted to tease
the biggest thing possible in addition
some of the actors already have
contracts for multiple movies co-writer
of the first movie Greg Russo told
collider that he personally sees the
reboot as a Trilogy the first movie
takes place before the tournament the
second movie during it and Mortal Kombat
3 after so the chances are good that the
war between Earth and outworld as the
grand finale will have to wait a little
longer perhaps in favor of the
tournament which will be anything but
clear-cut at the end of part one Cole
Young sets off to recruit a number of
other champions for the upcoming fight
much to the Delight of fans it becomes
apparent that Johnny Cage is involved in
Mortal Combat 2 the Hollywood star is
one of the most frequently recurring
characters in the entire franchise at
first glance he is characterized by his
big mouth and his selfish and
materialistic nature over the course of
the games however he develops into one
of the most important fighters on Earth
and is considered a faithful and loyal
companion it can therefore be strongly
assumed that the fan favorite will play
a major role in the
sequel there's there has been one
question above all others since the
release of the previous movie who will
play Johnny Cage in Mortal Kombat 2 well
the role of the iconic character will be
played by Carl Urban who should be
familiar to most movie and series
viewers thanks to the Amazon hit series
The Boys as a result fans were very
excited when Urban was confirmed for the
role of Johnny Cage for many he was the
perfect fit for the character at the
start of filming producer Todd Garner
posted a photo showing Urban together
with the majority of the cast actor
Lewis tan known from Shadow and Bone and
Deadpool 2 was already a B to make an
impression in part one in the role of
Cole Young and will thus also return in
Mortal Kombat 2 also reprising the roles
are Jessica mamy as Sonia blade and Josh
Lawson as Kano others already confirmed
include tadan Buu asano as Raiden hiruki
Sonata as Scorpion and the raid star Joe
taslim as Subzero besides Johnny Cage
other new additions await us the cast of
the action movie will be joined by tati
Gabrielle as Jade and Adeline Rudolph as
Princess Katana it was also revealed via
deadline that Martin Ford will take on
the role of the mighty conqueror Xiao
khah Desmond kayam will play King Jared
an a two win will be seen as Queen
sindal and Damon Harryman will appear as
quanchi anyone who has listened
carefully will have noticed that some
characters who actually died in the
predecessor will be making an appearance
director Simon mccoid said that the game
series had already shown various ways in
which characters who had already been
killed off could return to the story of
Mortal Kombat we are curious to find out
how exactly this will happen in the
movie
sequel with the first movie Simon MC
celebrated his directing debut and he
will also assume this position in Mortal
Kombat to the screenwriter is Jeremy
Slater who previously worked on the
Disney series moonight with Oscar Isaac
and also worked on Netflix's quirky
superhero series The Umbrella Academy he
is joined on the script by Ed Boon the
creator of the video games the movie is
being produced in part by James Juan and
Michael clear with their production
company Atomic
monster although filming on Mortal
Kombat 2 started in June 2023 it was
then put on hold for a long time due to
the actors and writer strike as was the
case with many other Productions with
the end of the strikes work can finally
resume but it remains unclear how long
production will last and whether the
previously envisaged release in 2024 is
still realistic nevertheless Mortal
Kombat 2 is expected to hit theaters in
2025 at the
latest so what's next for the film
series in a podcast for variety magazine
Subzero actor Joe taslam spoke about
having signed on for a total of four
more Mortal Kombat movies according to
him the future of the series is of
course also dependent on the success of
the second part yet this announcement
might give us hope for the time being as
it seems that they still believe in the
potential of the
franchise how do you feel about it did
you like the reboot and are you looking
forward to the sequel which story lines
from the games would you like to see in
the movies share your thoughts in the
comments and give this video a thumbs up
if you'd like to see more videos like
this in the
[Music]
future